are these the three most powerful devil  fruits in one piece and number three  we've got Luffy's fruits the Nika fruit  this fruit lets Luffy stretch to the  limits of imagination just like a looney  Toon's character he can morph his body  and his surroundings into any shape he  desires not many powers can do it like  this one can do at number two we've got  trophalga lawsuit a fruit so op it's  called the ope open inside his operating  room he has control over just about  everything that's right from body  swapping to decapitation to a low-cost  medical treatment the opeopenomi will  leave you in Shameless but what then is  the strongest fruit of Alto while the  Nico fruit and the opeopenomi fruit are  about to get burnt because Marco's  Phoenix fruit is flying into the top  spot it's strong enough to hold off  dinosaurs and his blue healing Flames  help him recover from damage Crazy Fast  And as an added bonus this man gets to  just lie around no boat necessary